the European Union's audiovisual sector
will not be included in negotiations on
a major trade pact with the United
States he use education youth culture
and sport council has been told the
reassurances came from EU Trade
Commissioner Karel De Gucht who leads
negotiations on the transatlantic trade
and investment partnership on behalf of
the EU the request culture ministers but
also in general the European Council to
exempt the audiovisual sector from these
negotiations is something which he will
keep to faithfully this is very
important love you the cultural sector
including audio-visual works has always
enjoyed different treatment in
international trade negotiations in part
to help guarantee Europe's cultural
diversity but the United States remains
keen to put the issue up for negotiation
despite Europe's red lines in the sport
format the minister's encouraged EU
countries to develop policies and action
plans for eliminating gender stereotypes
and promoting gender equality in sport
this includes the prevention of
gender-based violence and protecting
victims of harassment the council urge
members to consider registration systems
interviews or reference requirements to
ensure that only suitable people work in
sport particularly with minors as the
financial crisis places a heavy burden
on countries hosting major sports
competitions in Europe The ministers
also discussed ways to promote the
long-term economic social and
environmental benefits of major sport
events in the youth segment ministers
adopted a resolution on an EU work plan
for youth the player names to develop
jobs and learning opportunities for
young people as youth unemployment rates
in Europe saw the plan set to run for 18
months and will be evaluated toward the
end of next year